well thanks Stanford etl for having me a
couple of quick disclaimers uh I'm dar
mesh by the way I on Twitter as it turns
out as well and I'm CTO so that means
this is not my natural state of being my
natural state of being is writing Python
code not being a public speaker so bear
with me if I sound nervous it's because
I'm nervous I get better though trust me
so my claim to sudo fame is I found a
company called hubspot about nine a half
years ago it's grown went public about a
year ago and doing well pub spots in the
marketing and sales software space but
this is not about hubspot actually we
can talk about people and culture let's
get through this this is the Gucci itís
ringing of the bell photo that must be
included in every company's slide deck
in at least 24 months after they go
public so this is us some of you might
be wondering like Darr mesh why don't
you look like more excited that's me
excited right there that's as excited as
I get and so what's that why the sort of
close someone at the very last minute
one of our I think one of our marketing
people said you know what we should do
something like noteworthy remarkable
that people ask us exactly why the
sunglasses no reason it's like why not
it's um so that was it's like Darvish
put these sunglasses on like okay fine
so the company's done well we just
assess tom mentioned we just had our
quarterly earnings call and so the
company's about 180 million dollars in
revenue last year growing fifty-seven
percent which means something because
that's actually really hard to do with
that scales we're proud of that that's
the last braggy sled i think i have so
we can kind of get on with business this
is a safe harbor statement which
basically says i may make
forward-looking statements and if i do
the future may not be what i said it was
going to be and don't buy stock based on
things that i say i'm paraphrasing but
that's what it that's what it says it's
an SEC requirement and I didn't do this
for fun just for entertainment value so
one big disclaimer is so hot spots been
successful and I've been talking to
entrepreneurs for a long long time and
realize this is like one things that
happens with startup advice generally is
you have this kind of what I think it
was like extrapolation from a data point
of one is actually called we did this
and
things happen so that must have been the
right thing to do so not all unicorns
dispense thing not everything they did
was right and not all the things that
they say are necessarily applicable so
that's my ticket take it as it is so I'm
going to kind of tell you a story here
in terms of my life story well
fast-forward through my times of the
dusty streets of India and how that
informed my notion of unity economics
and SAS businesses but um so I went to
school here for grad school that's
what's MIT what some of you may recall
me like the other school on that other
coast somewhere which it is and while
they're at grad school I met this guy
his name's Brandon hot brian halligan
and he's my co-founder he's a CEO
hubspot right so we met about 11 years
ago in in grad school and the one
problem was that Brian was was in
business school working towards an MBA
any MBA students here few that will
confess especially I would that lead up
right it's like okay um there's by at
least a few of you that wouldn't raise
your hand okay and so the question is
like well why is that a problem during
mesh is just because uh he was an MBA
and so because there was this prevailing
theory oops um in start-up land I said
okay well let's say your probability of
success for some definition of success
is roughly one percent picture of the
skull for getting to a billion dollars
or whatever it is and then there's
factors that impact that probability one
of which is this kind of very
exponential kind of factor where n is
equal to number of MBAs on the early
team and so that's been like a
long-running thesis within the shop
community for as long as that I've known
this startup community so I'm like okay
well you know startups are hard and I'm
about to start this thing with a
co-founder that you know like right out
of the gate our odds have gone down
fifty percent and then like 30 seconds
later I had the realization that I also
was in business school working towards
it's like okay well now that's too so
okay so so that's my co-founder and I
CEO and CTO and then we went on to hire
a VP of Marketing a VP of Sales a VP of
customer success and a VP of engineering
all of which were MBA is all from MIT
Sloan and it's like what could possibly
go wrong with this picture right it's a
and so the reason I'm telling you this
is like the talk is about is about peep
one culture and one of things i've
learned so i'm an engineering guy like i
like i like code i don't like being not
i'm not psychopathic i'm just antisocial
i like humans okay just don't being or
like around them a lot right it's iLike
I some humans but i'm going to posit
this thesis to you that not all MBAs are
like genetically predisposed to start up
failure they're not all Schmucks they're
not all chumps there are actually some
good ones that can contribute value and
i think one of the mistakes folks like I
make is we can underestimate the value
of like non-engineering non-product
people as it turns out especially in
this day and age it takes it takes more
than just building a great product
actually build something successful and
I've learned this and so the nice thing
about MBAs is there the better ones
which we tried to hire our like super
analytical and they're not all just kind
of the paper pushing whatever it is like
syrio typical notion that you have about
business school students so I just
wanted to spell the myth right here go
on record and say MBAs are not all bad
all right so the thing I'm going to talk
about here is its culture and when I
talk to talk to startups most of them
don't spend a lot of time thinking about
culture and thinking about people it's
like okay and I'm going to walk you
through some of the recombinant why
entrepreneurs like culture one is a
culture we've got that figured out we've
got margarita Monday's we've got a ping
pong table we're going to do Star Trek
movies on Friday afternoons or something
like that so that's rationalization
number one number two is culture well
that's just something that happens
organically don't create culture that
just sounds kind of creepy and kind of
fishy irregular that's why we don't we
don't do that and then there's one of my
favorites is like we're friggin change
the role put in denton universe that's
our culture and so okay and so those are
the kind of common buckets of reasons
why early stage companies don't talk
about culture and the most common one
and this is actually a legitimate one is
we've got a thousand things to do we're
trying to raise funding would trying to
build product we're trying to find
co-founders we're trying to figure out
how to replace the vp of engineering
that was supposed to quit as thing and
didn't quit his thing is like all those
things that are happening in early-stage
land you don't have time to think about
people in culture which is probably the
best reason and I'm going to pause it to
you that despite all those reasons that
not only should you think about culture
you should obsess over as early in the
process it's
possible because of all the things you
will do that will have the time that you
can spend yes build the product but
people is the thing that will cause this
startup to succeed or fail and the
culture is going to define we'll talk
about this who you bring it as a
co-founder the early team and that's
going to actually influence your overall
probability of success more than most
other things that we will do most of you
will start companies where the likely
that your you able to build a product is
relatively high that's going to be fine
the what's really the kind of stopping
point sometimes is either there's no
market or you have a falling out with
the early team those are like a common
causes of a start-up stagnation or
failure so the other reason to walk you
through some of the arguments in favor
of culture we all know that all the time
in calories you spend in product is good
time and energy because the better the
product is the easier it is to track
users and customers not counterintuitive
at all that makes sense I'm going to
project that there's a direct analogy
around culture the better your culture
is the easier will be for you to tract
co-founders and employees eventually
customers investors and other things
that actually matters it's going to
sound cliché dump latitudinal because
it's cliched and platitude no but the
overall purpose of a culture the idea
behind it is to a attract amazing people
then help them do their best work that's
why you have it that's why you should
have a good one versus a crappy one and
the other one is like this I've seen
happen so many times so bad crappy
culture and their multiple toxic
cultures will not likely kill you
immediately there's not the fastest way
to die they're much faster ways to kill
a start-up this is the most reliable it
will kill you if the cultures crappy is
just a matter of time it will not can't
last so and then this is the for the
economically and mathematically oriented
there is relatively convincing evidence
this one slide around this is a
comparison of the S&P 500 based on the
survey of the happiness of the employees
at those companies and their overall
performance on the public markets right
so easily it's like okay so culture sort
of matters least is the correlation we
may not be able to draw a direct
causality but there's a correlation
between companies with happy employees
tend to do better performance wise on
the market all right
having said all that hubspot in our
first three years we're about nine
something years old now we did not use
the word culture at all and I know this
because neither my co-founder I we don't
have phone calls I don't have phone
calls generally at all as it turns out
in quirky that way so everything we've
ever said to each other has been in
late-night emails from 11pm to about 2
a.m. we have these long thousand-word
emails that go back and forth i look
back to the archives like oh when did we
first start talking about culture it was
three years in so we didn't do it and
then this happened so what in my
co-founder of the CEO hubspot went to a
CEO group which the easiest way to think
about as a group therapy for CEOs like
so they all go in and talk about issues
of the day which is super useful i
highly recommend it and so at this
particular session that he went to the
the theme was culture and and we're
still in our con early stages and and so
he has I guess I keep on thinking to
reveal the names anyway but he had some
highfalutin CEOs in his group and and
Brian's reaction my co-founders like
well culture he had that last excuse was
like we don't have time for that we're
trying to build this business were
building a product or trying to get
customers we're doing all these things
who has time for culture and they beat
him up over it they're like no you do
not understand your job as a CEO this is
like this cannot be any higher on the
priority list like it should be number
one you should do it and so Bryan not
his head got through that meeting then
the next meeting that I had with him
over beers he's like Dermot I've heard
this culture thing is really really
important why don't you go do that now
that presenter problem because on the
extrovert too introverted scale I'm like
way over there like way like it's
possibly way over there right it's uh
and so it's not I you know don't like
humans are some that I do like hanging
around with us my wife and child a
gratuitous photo of the children and so
then it's like okay I you know Brian's
busy he's doing other things all he's
really asking me to do is like what I
thought my mission was going to be was
okay well we you know we have a culture
I just need to like collect some data
and ask our employees what culture is
what they think about it they like it or
not it's a data collection kind of like
right down and be described for the
culture that already exists like yeah
not pleasant I rather be writing code
but okay fine I'll take one for the team
and within days this was my reactions
it's like this is the worst possible
thing I've ever done to myself in the
history of me it was so bad it was bad
on so many levels it was crazy i'll give
you one anecdote so i started like
sending emails around sent by the way i
like I'm I'm working on this thing I'm
trying to figure out culture at the
company and then I got these uh like
flaming response flaming responses and
I'm used to flaming responses from from
hubspot employees telling me I'm Aetna
get for many different reasons but this
one was particularly particularly acute
and hard to think they're like oh so now
we're talking about culture next it's
going to be like posters on the wall and
it's this is the first step down the
slippery slope and then this is one that
killed me is like this is not the
company that I thought I joined like
you're killing me here what I all they
asked you is are you happy or not what
do you think that's like wow and people
have this very visceral reaction when
you start talking about kind of people
issues and culture and so I sent this
email this is unedited directly to my
phone finder which I'm going to
paraphrase and say well I'll read it not
sure Ohio wound up being the guy to lead
the discussion on culture but it's
freaking hard eventually we need to give
this to someone that actually likes
humans this is late night email about
two or three months after that original
kind of interaction so I I didn't drop
it I'm like okay let's get back to thing
whatever will work through these issues
whatever I do think it's important I was
going off and reading on what other
people do and it turns out the data
suggests that so we did a survey and ask
the employees are you happy or not would
you recommend pub spot as a place to
work scale 0-10 and the reality was good
which is up they were super happy
ecstatically happening maniacally happy
that was the good news the second
question we asked is okay well why did
you give us that score and we only had
this kind of recursion problem the
reason the people at HubSpot we're happy
was because of the other people at
HubSpot it's like well I don't know what
to do with that which is okay well start
with happy people and don't lose them I
guess and then they will attract more
people that will also be happy so this
was this was a challenge we work through
this so this is actually this is the
last raggy slide I forgot I had this one
in there
so glassdoor does this kind of
nationwide survey of employees anonymous
luckily Yelp for how many people heard
of last door who's curious okay oh she's
let all of you all right so they do this
thing and unsurprisingly last year
Google is number one you Facebook they
and I just pulled out the tech companies
done folks that you would know this is
one things we're most proud of this is
this year scores so we came in at number
4 i'm going to talk you through yeah
it's like what happened along the story
so that's that's the last braggy slide
and so the approach we took in terms of
culture is we took the kind of
engineering very geeked out way of
thinking about it which is okay well
culture what it really is what i think
about it it's like the operating system
that everything else is kind of running
on its like the heart is the machinery
that makes us run and we should kind of
build it as such and so i subsequently
spent hundreds of hours it's this is
like the floor i know it's bigger than
this this is all i'm willing to admit to
and the real pain was the fact that
those 300 hours were not spent writing
python code they were spent writing a
powerpoint deck trying to describe
culture at HubSpot we thought it was
what we think it needed to be and
resulted in this deck called house pop
culture code and we made the weird
decision about a couple of years after
we kind of started that process just
like oh well this is useful like in the
kind of open source mentality we have
this uh very kind of transparent culture
like I will put it out there to see if
this is useful to other people and it's
been wildly popular for reasons that are
not completely clear I think it's
because the topics on people's minds so
that's done well and what I'm gonna do
thing I talk you through some of the
kind of mechanics of how we came up with
the stuff we came up with and some of
the things that I think are useful this
is not to tell you about hubspot culture
and what it's like it's to tell you
about the thought process that went to
some of the things that I think are
generally generally good so the first
thing we kind of recognized that our
first kind of observation was that all
of us you know humanity overall people
that work for companies and startups all
over I had kind of dramatically changed
how they live and work so in the left
column of the things that people used to
care about that was their thing
in the right column is the way they are
now right and most of you will have like
especially the under generation will nod
your head like yeah I can't believe
what's up pension like what is that and
like it went it's inconceivable to any
of us so we're going to spend an entire
career people did this by the way back
in the day they spent their entire
professional career in one company and
that was the thing that you did and I
was like what like whatever I'm not like
no I'm not staying here friend I'm
definitely not anyway and so our
reaction was like okay well it looks
like a lot of these companies are
essentially frozen in time there they've
got this thing that they're doing that
makes no sense for the current reality
in terms of the people that are working
there are people they want to attract it
just doesn't make any sense so we went
out to fix that and this that starts
with the hold the captcha code kind of
described so here's what's broken here's
how we think I'm not going to bore you
with this stuff and and this is going to
sound less I'm gonna skip by this
actually even though it's like the most
importance line the deck but i'll put it
up there for a little while this one is
it's crucial i love this quote and the
idea here is most of the dysfunctions
that exist in a start-up or a company of
any size most of them happen in dark
corners behind closed doors or when the
stupidest stuff happens and if you can
shine light into those things that are
happening right now the likelihood of
stupidity just flat-out stupidity goes
down so if like there's like two people
trying to make a decision like okay
we're going to go geographies through
air and then we will reveal to the
employees what we came up with you are
much more likely to make very stupid
decisions in those circumstances so the
more light you can shine into the
process overall the better the outcome
by the decision as a result of that we
made the decision early on in the
company to share just about everything
with everyone period the only different
only exceptions where if we were legally
bound not to share it like if we were
working on some M&A transaction where we
had a contractual obligation not to
share it or and we can talk about this
in the Q&A if we need you're curious
individual compensation data because it
was data that we felt like we didn't
exclusively own as the company it was
kind of a shared data thing between the
individual and us everything else the
board deck the financials how much money
we burned when we're going to run out of
cash what the overall valuations were
what discussions we were having with VCS
everything which
with everyone and that was that worked
out well the other thing we did the
savvy this quick hacks we have a very
open culture lots of people do that what
something that a lot of people don't do
i'll give you the anecdote here so we
start off just my co-founder I we're in
this room with four desks common startup
environment actually that's probably we
were like living luxuriously because
it's like two desks are open that was
amazing and so then we hired the first
employees like okay well like where
should that person sit and it seemed
unfair originally it's like okay well
why should we have just because we
happen to be here so we did is like we
had this hack it's like okay what we'll
do is we'll do a random lottery and
we'll pick desks and and we did it
because we're geeked out we're like okay
well it's not lay whoever gets it gets
the window seat because that's you know
because not everybody wants the window
seat so who as your turn came up in the
lottery you got to pick whichever the
open desk where left be essentially very
very simple simple hack and then what we
did it was like okay well every time we
hire someone we're going to go reshuffle
desks then go through the lottery
process again so employee number four
and play number ten employed number 52
employee number eight and all along the
way people told us well that's just
crazy like yeah it worked at ten people
maybe 50 I don't know how you do it 200
people 400 people and we kept going and
if I think back on it now in terms of
like simple hacks can you imagine the
countless hours that has saved just from
raw office politics now a lot of you are
young and so you haven't had the
mind-numbing experience of like arguing
over like one inch of like office space
like wait a second Suzy has a better
thing than I do or what I think it's we
avoided all of that right trying to
think through all that just just that
one simple hack so the moral story by
the way there is get the simple hacks in
early as much hard to make those kinds
of changes later the other one that's
interesting so we have this kind of
hyper transparent culture of share
everything and this is something we had
to add later the deck because there was
much confusion around it's like welder
mesh I thought we were transparent but
then this decision get made in it I
don't remember being asked for like a
vote it's like well no transparency
means we will tell you how the process
works what's going into it but someone
owns that decision we do not make
decisions by consensus someone owns it
and we trust them to make the right
decision so transparency is not the same
thing as democracy
this one another hack so as we were
growing it's like okay well we have to
like do things and have some guidelines
around sick time and vacations and stuff
like that and we didn't have that as we
were growing looks like our chief
console and our CFO said okay well now
is the time to start writing down like
get an employee manual together and put
all this stuff together we need
guidelines and we said we don't want to
do that is it legally required well no
not technically it's not legally
required but you should we should happen
so we made exactly three words as our
policy for everything unless otherwise
stated which is using a judgment show
you buy a round of drinks i'm at this
event its really snowing i know you guys
won't experience this but it's really
snowing hard outside should i come into
the office so can I stay home and work
from home because we don't we don't care
we care but we don't care in terms of
what decision you make now skip through
this in the interest of time let data
make it's the geeked out most of the
engineering folks in here will
appreciate this don't use rank
essentially nice kind of I'm gonna try
to get to the q 8 i've tried spitting
through this because i'm sensing that
yeah that we should be going to it and
walk you through some of the land mines
this is like the first thing they teach
you when you're doing like a public
present like when i'm reading the press
like i do not end on a dark note so I'm
dark no tom is first thing you learn
this I kind of hinted at this in the
beginning parts is that like the
immediate reactions like okay well the
first rule of cultures you do not talk
about culture right that was the
immediate reaction I got from the
employee base what I've learned since
then is in order for it to work you have
to talk about it incessantly like inset
what you have to keep like this is what
it is because as you're growing you
think that like oh well everybody kind
of gets this like we've been around like
no they don't I guarantee you they don't
get it and as you're kind of a teeny
people so you have to keep talking about
it first decide what it is and then
communicated constantly the other one
this is back to software like some
people is like okay well these are our
values and this is what it is and this
is the way it's going to be because our
founders said so 20 years ago or
whatever it is that doesn't work culture
is more like software than hardware
let's i give sort of parallel
perspective you should be entering on it
and building it just like you would a
product so our culture codec
version 37 of the ones that we publicly
published right so we keep going back as
I call well this is quite not quite
right we find bugs in it we have a
backlog of a request and change requests
in things like I someday want to put it
into github and tues appetit so we
haven't figured out yet but anyway so
this is the other doc one this is the PI
the biggest reason you should invest
some time and deciding what your culture
is those that are engineering understand
the notion of Technology debt so
technology debt is you take this
shortcut you hack something together and
you put it out there because in the
interest of time youse want to get it
out there and you know that was happy
code and you're gonna have to go fix it
someday and pay off the debt similar to
financial dead I need the cash now and
I'm willing to pay a sum interest rate
and pay it off in the future because the
cash right now is necessary same thing
with technology yet and there is such a
thing as culture debt and culture debt
is yeah this person is sort of a jerk
but they're so good and we've been
recruiting between trying to find this
designer for like two and a half months
they're the best one we've seen so far
and we have no idea when the next one's
gonna come along that we really like but
I don't really want to be around them
and you'll rationalize like oh yeah but
they'll just work remotely it'll be fine
it's usually not fine what ends up
happening is that they make everybody
around them miserable everybody that
comes in interviews with the company if
that interacts with that person's like
okay well this is I don't want to work
for this company they won't tell you
that right because they're interviewing
and the funny thing is about we need to
incur technology debt you can go back
and say you know what I wrote this
hockey code it's really slow or really
buggy or something's happening i am
going to pay this debt off i'm going to
rewrite this is going to be beautiful
i'm going to refactor the code it's
going to be awesome culture debt you
might do the same thing like the
parallel would be is like oh we're gonna
we discover this person's a jerk we're
gonna let them go right that's now the
difference is that when you refactor
that code you've basically paid off your
debt when you fire that person that was
a jerk you haven't completely paid off
the debt because the things that they
like the planted mines the people there
it's like you're still kind of be
rooting out you will never know whether
you completely got rid of some of the
toxicity they left behind it's amazing
how much impact especially in an early
team that can have so be very very
careful and it's easy for me to say
right and it's in this but it's so
tempting likes
okay we just need this person will
figure out later it will be okay it
won't as it turns out it'll be okay but
will be painful it's not worth it the
other one that's interesting so when we
came out with the early iterations of
the culture code deck and how spots
culture we're like okay we've got it
we've gotten all the feedback this is
what our culture is awesome like our
work is done here and then like
engineers will come back it's like well
Ramesh I know the culture code says like
oh we believe anyone can work from
anywhere that's what it says in dec
that's our philosophy like we don't
believe in specific office locations
whatever we like the freedom of working
from anywhere and our vp of engineering
comes along and says well i don't like
that like we think we do much better
work on Rico located that's example so
what ends up happening is that you have
this what I think I was like the federal
versus state issue so the issue here is
you're going to have what you will think
it was like kind of federal law like
these are the things that are inviolate
right so we think of is like the
inalienable rights of a hub spiral we
will not take transparency way no one
can decide that you don't get access to
the financials those are something
you'll be healed in violet we won't
change it but then there are certain
things like okay well this is our
overall philosophy but individual group
disagrees with that particular structure
that particular guideline they're
welcome to override as long as you can
kind of convince their team and if it's
the right thing to do so that's that
always shows up anytime you have more
than two people or one person that
you'll personality there's always these
kind of subcultures that that develop in
a group all right so everyone wants to
hire for culture fit this is a last dark
slide and then I'm going to happen and a
happy note I'm going to go on a very
very short rant but it's an important
one I talked to entrepreneurs and people
all the time that says we hire for
culture fit like we we hire for cult and
then my questions that awesome that you
hire for culture fit what's your culture
just like this rugged I'm not like
trying to be aggressive I'm not gonna
not a confrontational guy but like what
is it I'm curious and if you can't tell
me what your culture is that means when
you say we hire for culture fit that
means you hire people just like yourself
and you're using culture as a shorthand
for being able to like hire people just
like yourself so you should not be
allowed to say that we hire for culture
fit unless you can tell people what that
culture
is otherwise you have these kind all
sorts of biases that kick in and that's
a very very dangerous thing so this is
one of the probably most important
reasons to write your culture down he
doesn't have to be 128 slide PowerPoint
deck like we have but it should be
written down even if it's an email like
it's something has to exist that people
have access to so they know what it is
and then a closing note is every company
however many people is going to have a
culture cultures exist period anytime
more than one person is together and
with a few calories not suggesting you
go off and spend hundreds of hours but
every hour five hours ten hours you
spend in those early days have dramatic
leverage so might as well build a
culture you're going to love and build a
company want to work for and work in so
thank you and I will take questions yes
yeah I haven't I haven't had an official
oh sorry yes question is uh have I ever
had a mentor that kind of guided me and
kind of helped me through the process
the answer is no no official mentor I
think that not that I wouldn't have
wanted one or I didn't think would be
useful I don't have the personality I'm
because I myntra I'm not going to reach
out to some random person it's like oh
can you be my mentor like it's feels a
little bit awkward to me that that was
stupid of me honestly because it would
have been useful but but I've read a lot
so I feel like I know people that are in
the community I've gotten better about
it now so now I will kind of reshef
there's like someone my peer group
companies going through some more issues
and i'll have like random dinners with
the mothers no official mentor
relationship but I strongly advise it
I've known people that have mentors and
most of them swear by them that there's
like it's an awesome thing go here out
yep so in most organizations I've seen
my culture seems it like it has to be
different at the top level what we
if you were in an organization where the
leadership does not want to focus on
culture they need okay so the question
is often culture needs to come down from
the kind of from the top and kind of
define the culture and what do you do an
organization where leadership is not
bought into bought into that kind of
process so a couple things one is
cultures correctly done the only weight
real way they stick is it has to be a
collaborative process with a team
because if I had tried which I sort of
did in the early like okay well here's
what I think you know culture should be
because I read a lot i know things I've
been around the company a bunch you get
revolting people just don't buy it so it
doesn't work so that's number one is
cultures can't be created by e dick it
has to be through this kind of
collaborative process that ideally would
be transparent now then the question is
around okay well what if you know the
leadership of the company just doesn't
value culture send my link this video
and I'll help make the pitch but it's
it's it's hard you have to kind of help
them recognize the importance of it may
be introduced them neither to summit
trail or some persons kind of live
through it because most people that have
been kind of been through the process in
both directions no one will argue no one
I know has ever Argus like well darn
mash you know we spend a little bit
about that whole culture thing that was
highly overrated not once have I heard
that not once so yes we'll go here then
we'll go back oops what kind of
questions do you ask 22 when you're
hiring people to determine so what kind
of questions do I asked in order to
determine culture fit so we have this
kind of set of five attributes that we
solve for and it's yeah and one of them
is humility it's like number one it's
like yeah humility effectiveness and
transparency and there's a bunch of them
and and so we do is we ask questions
that are geared around all five of the
attributes essentially and so we have a
separate set of questions so we have the
things that test for skill set do you
know the things that you need to do to
do this job but then the other ones
around we trying to whittle out is
someone humble or not like it's uh as it
turns out I don't even need to interview
someone in order to figure that out I
have a very very high highly sensitized
Ralphie accurate arrogance detector I
can I can luli I can tell in like three
sent email whether someone where the
kind of generally fall on the cannoli
versus arrogance and ego scale so what
we do is that we and every person
interviews at HubSpot has a different
thing in terms of how they weed out the
things but every higher and every
promotion we rate the people on there
how they fit the culture is actual like
okay was this person how not just when
they get hired but every point so if you
are not humble I say you snuck in
somehow because you kind of faked it I
don't know how you do that but listen
you did you it will get caught
eventually because every promotion every
review process we stick okay well on a
scale of 0-10 was this person
transparent you think of this person is
being transparent so that gets home so
yeah we're a little bit draconian about
I guess is by the best word i'm going to
go here then i'll come back excuse me
yep yes i have it finished a former
question who owns the 120-page
powerpoint deck you were talking about
like it's collaborative analysis said
that decisions aren't made by consensus
is it you or is it the head of HR a
great question so it's exactly hundred
twenty eight slides by the way in case
you're curious has always been hundred
well not for years it has been every
time i add a slight i take a slide away
so it's exactly that way puts a
constraint on and i own it in terms of
being described for the deck so it's the
kind of benevolent dictator for life and
open source world kind of thing so i
take contributions i'll take put
essentially the equivalent a pull
request and then I'll weave it in and
i'll put it out there for for comment
and then RFC form within the companies
like okay here's what the next version
the deck looks like what do you think
often I get flamed but then I kind of
way that it back and forth it's like
okay well there's still overall even
though it's not done by by anyway I own
it so every change that's made every
every war than I read slide I on yeah
yes sioux nation that crisp aaron c is
fought the biggest advantages and a
company so are there any challenges
associated with having such a
transparent culture George there are
child question is you know transparent
such a big part of big part of the
culture are there any challenges are
downsides there are challenges but there
most people overweight the danger
involved the risk involved in being
hyper transparent so when we started
doing this right when we were first of
all tell you the hack because an
interesting one when we hired our first
employee
so first it was just my co-founder and I
you know how did the third person coming
to the team one of the decisions we have
to make is like okay well what do we
tell this person like that was like the
decision we have to make and my co fine
i look at each other's like well the
easiest path is like telling everything
right it's like that's an easy easy
binary can I choice and so then we just
kept doing that and then as we grew our
board advisors people Tess like okay
well yeah that's fine right now but what
happens when you guys are out raising
the funding round and they can see the
cash balance kind of depleting and they
know you've been on the road for five
weeks and it's like the cash is going to
run or like what happens then and as it
turns out nothing it's like even though
always gone to those dark periods and
the funny thing is so so yes there's
risk involved but winds up happening
when you have a hyper transparent
culture when you know what the rules are
so we had a type of transparent culture
you end up hiring people there are way
unlikely to take advantage or abuse that
trust right looks like okay well if we
didn't have that transferred like we can
hire people's like okay well is this
someone that we feel like we can like
reveal overall financial so that we can
tell this will they use this against us
will they and in nine and a half years
we have 1,100 employees in the company
you have never had a breach of trust
right in this is crazy and we've had
lots of people in we grow fast we've had
people leave so I would still highly
recommend doing it yes there are
challenges but the upside is immense
number one is as a society we value
transparency a lot especially like early
stage especially in start-up land I was
going to run this diabolical
experimented hubspot and I use the word
diabolical because that's the word to
use that's what it is it's going to go
ask people that when they were hires
like okay we have this thing we have is
very transparent culture here's this
kind of server that we have this wiki
that we have all these documents and all
this information you can have access to
that or you can get ten percent more and
comp if you just don't care about that
that was like okay what's the actual
economic value the people just place on
the kind of access to information
they're trained what do you really want
that badly I didn't run the experiment
my thesis is if we had to run the
experiment just about everyone would
have said I want access to the
information because it gives you a level
of security that you know what's going
on not that you need to like contribute
to every decision
but once again it's like okay well I can
start a plant it's a very crazy thing
this is one of things when you're
recruiting which is going to do when you
start building the company you're
convincing the overall kind of goal of a
early-stage startup is to convince
exceptionally smart people to do this
very stupid thing which is join you in
this kind of crazy thing that has
doesn't make any sense right like if you
like objectively looked at it's like why
would they do that what transparencies
allows you to do is at least make some
convincing argument like okay we're
completely this is completely crate at
least you'll know what's going on and it
gives you yeah lots of leverage in terms
of recruiting and things like that so I
think we had a question here now yes
then I'll go back this way so back to
the example of the individual with a
fabulous skill set who's a jerk yep I I
think you sort of put out there the
binary decision to keep them and incur
the cultural debt or get rid of numbers
and I'm wondering whether the middle
ground of may be working with them to
help them to you know some or other
incorporator and opportunity to the
culture in a way that actually comes up
with the win-win yep what's your
perception on that because the question
is I'm going to pair it on the short in
it which is when you have mistakenly
hired a jerk you have two options one is
you can kind of develop them into less
dirtiness versus just letting them go
and what's the experience my experience
has been there's actually two kinds of
jerks one kind of jerk so it met so
sometimes actually normal good people
manifests as jerks because it's just
like they're in their heads and they
just come off that way and my mind the
the discriminating factor what makes one
a jerk in the other one not really is
like what they're solving for right
there are people that are like I'm a
little bit this way I'm super analytical
and I will like this like I will
question like everything right so like
and that's just like academic in me a
little bit but I like to think about
think of myself as not a jerk and the I
saw they eat so the difference is are
they being jerky just to belittle
someone else are they doing out of their
own ego are they just doing it because
that's just their way of getting inputs
or something like that it's in their
nature but they're still solving for the
greater good right so we have people
that are skeptics and this is one this
is actually really good one so there's
cynics and there are skeptics the little
definition for a cynic is not only that
they don't believe that good thing is
happy
they're cynical they don't believe good
is possible that's the literal like
distinction of skeptic is skeptical but
they will say I'm kind of skeptical of
this particular decision but the reason
they're expressing that skepticism is
because they they believe they have the
hope that will get better and that's why
they're sharing it cynics are different
jerks similar kind of parallel which is
some jerks are just doing it to belittle
people because that's how they think
they kind of raise their own value it's
yeah hard to tell sometimes but yeah
that's the distinction hold i'm going to
go wait that person had a hand up
earlier i don't i don't know how i know
that but okay you know looking at the
list in terms of companies that people
really enjoyed working at most of them
seem to be successful companies that
were doing very well yeah right um how
about when things don't go go but there
are layoffs going on yes then you have a
mortgage your kids yep you know you have
a lot of stress in your life yep and
people really tend to you know kind of
develop different attitudes and
personalities and things 49 what's your
experience you know dealing with those
situations because that's when you
really need culture that's when you
really need people to come together yep
yep what's your question so the question
is you know successful companies tend to
show up on those kind of happy employees
list because they have the resources
they can kind of do the things that are
necessary how do you do that when
resources are limited when going through
dark times possible layoffs and my
answer is this is like the real culture
is not about you know ping pong tables
and beer fridays and things like that
it's it's about these kind of core first
principles kind of stuff in my
experience what's happened this is tough
spots my third startup right and I've
lived through layoffs I've lived through
company shutdowns I've lived through a
lot of different things and one thing
I've realized is that when you have the
right people on board and you're
transparent with them they will cut you
a lot of slack like I've had people
volunteer to take pay cuts because I
could tarnish I know we're not gonna be
able to meet payroll I love this company
I love what we're doing uh you know I'll
go to fifty percent salary and will do
its like I've end and that happens like
people are willing to live through the
pain as long as you're honest with them
the issues turns up is when you're going
through dark times and this misguided
notion of protecting the
from the reality that that's the
rationalization entrepreneur sometimes
use in in its not mal-intent they're
like oh well it's part of my job to
buffer the team from this darkness
that's happening over here right and you
have to be careful with that because you
don't want to just lay everything out
there out of your own kind of toys and
you just kind of share this misery or
something I've got it needs to be from
the greater good of company and for that
individual psyche okay this is something
they should know I know it's hard I know
it's tough but here's what we're going
through and that's the true test of a
culture is like if you have that in
place so and it's so interesting we so
every quarter for the last well six-plus
years so every three months we do an
employee survey to all employees across
the entire company that ask the exact
same question I asked in the first one
which is based on PS on a scale of 0-10
how likely are you are you to recommend
hubspot as a place to work and we've
been taking that data in every month for
six plus years and that is in our minds
like the leading indicator of how the
company is actually doing I can look at
the financials but if there's a problem
that's the canary in the coal mines like
okay we'll see that like and now we kind
of slice a little bit by group and bi
geography we have multiple offices it's
like okay well there's something wrong
in the sales group because you can see
it it's like okay there's something
wrong with leadership is usually what it
is something's going on and so what
what's interesting is that when we've
had our dark times we've had them our
NPS goes up employees are happier one of
the dark darker time it wasn't dark
because it went poorly when we in public
that was the thing the employees were
most worried about like okay well when
public companies go public this happens
because they're going to stop sharing
information with us because now there
are public know we're a publicly traded
company they can't do those kinds of
things our overall happiness as measured
can objectively that we've been doing
for years went up post-ipo than before
it's like we talked about it we came
through it put a couple of interesting
hacks in place one which I'm a big
hacked eyes when I tell you this for
that tell you earlier in the process of
going this is applicable I'm gonna tell
you anyway because it's fun so when we
were going public so you have this hyper
transparent culture share all the
financials with everybody put it all out
there all you know all thousand
employees and then our legal counsel and
bankers come back okay
now you're going public what you need to
do is you'd like figure out this kind of
group of insiders and there'll be
regulations around them in terms when
they can trade stock and all these
things and it's like and you should need
to pick who your list is going to be
your CFO or whatever it's like don't
measure if you want to be on that list
that's completely fine whatever okay and
then my co-founder my PA's it's like
okay well designate it's like okay well
like what's the regulation like how many
of them can we have it we're trying to
figure out like who should we leave and
so they come back it's like well there's
no like like limit like no league but
you know it's like usually in a 6 8 10
so we made every single employee a
designated insider every single one and
our chief counsel they thought we were
Creighton done before we didn't know
this at the time but it's like okay well
that's stupid like don't assume rules
that are in place it's like is that the
kind of stuff that I think gives people
confidence that just because we've been
public we're not going to go down and
crashing burning flame which me anyway
but hopefully won't be because of stupid
reasons like that but yeah yes you
mentioned that your co-founder went to
like a CEO roundtable discussion that
that was the impetus for or that started
in neutral tones ah can you comment in
terms of your own personal growth
professional growth in terms of your
journey it has body you have you
yourself found coaches or mentors your
own sort of like CTO round table to
discuss these issues with you could have
quite a very visceral intuitive sense of
how this all works no and yes it's
clearly you've digested this through
several layers as you copy this
experience yeah so the question is
around you know so sweet you get my CEO
went to this kind of CEO group question
is do I go have I been to those kind of
group things or whatever not formal ones
that exists what the one thing I've been
doing though but I've been doing it for
15-plus years now I do these informal
dinners with people that kind I know of
met online or of know and some people I
know some people i don't know every city
i travel into all these kind of random
ad-hoc dinners and i have a couple of
hacks as you might expect for these
dinners one is I never plan them in
advance I send to email the day of and
say oh by the way I'm in town my
schedules changed are you open for
dinner question number two is do you
know anyone else that you've been
wanting to meet or you think I should
meet and we'll have dinners from
anywhere from two people to 30
people on any given thing and the
overall and I don't label it as this but
it's what I call and I've done this now
semi-official i call it the founder
therapy dinner right and this is super
important and as I was going through it
and I try to get round tables instead of
square tables there's a bunch of
weirdness that goes into how I pick
venues and stuff I stand for solve for
acoustics because one have a
conversation and it's funny because what
ends up happening is that the same
dynamics that exist in group therapy
actually apply here and fifty percent of
problem the founders go through which is
a 50-percent problem that any kind of
issue you're dealing with is this kind
of belief that you're alone like I am
the only one living this thing wherever
there's something wrong with me and
that's why I'm having these problems if
I were a better founder I would not be
having these issues and i have found
overwhelming evidence that all founders
have almost the same issues same issues
most of them are people issues that it
turns out but they have the issues and
maybe they may be time shifted and based
on stage they've either live them but
they're living something i have not met
a single founder including ones that are
multi-billion dollar companies now that
says oh you have it was a really tough
fry those first three or four years but
boy is it easy now like I don't have any
like notin doesn't happen right so I
strongly encourage you as you're going
through this because a find a co-founder
or multiple co-founders because startup
life is super lonely like super super
lonely and if you misguidedly don't get
a co-founder find a peer group that you
can kind of talk to on a regular basis
and kind of vent and share and kind of
live the journey at least with someone
else yes people adjust some things
around kind of make the company look
good yeah i'm usually to instill
confidence in you know market do you
find that with having such transparency
specifically regard to financials that
that has the opposite effect with you
that it hurts maybe your stock price or
your investor it may so i'll tell you
our stance and we can determine the
market will determine whether hurt us or
help i think it helps us because we did
this on the road show so we did so we've
had these metrics inside the company for
all of our entire history so when went
on the road show we didn't read if
fine things like lifetime value and CAC
and the financials that you know SAS
companies or tech companies often report
and we said okay well here are the
financials we've been using literally
the financials we've been using to run
the business for the last you know seven
years and we didn't change a darn thing
right and so then it was much easier for
us to and like answer the questions or
whatever and yes it did not put us in as
positive a light as it might have but
the the street appreciated the
transparency they got it and it's and
we've in Fortune it's been you know
we're only about a little over a year in
for public quarters and they've been
positive financial you get the metrics
and things like that that helps
obviously but yeah listen I'm so here
and then we'll go console just curious
your I noticed yours your CEO and
co-founder wrote a book on marketing
lessons learned from the Grateful Dead
yeah and the openness of your culture
and transparency connected with
financial success seems to parallel that
I'm curious what are the lessons you
might have learned or build on from the
grateful that you mentioned the roadshow
just now yep um can you bring culturing
the Grateful Dead a little bit more
explicitly into focus here uh Wow okay
so the question is my co-founder brian
halligan he's a big he's a big deadhead
big found a Grateful Dead he wrote a
book on marking lessons from the
Grateful Dead and the question is can we
apply lessons from the Grateful Dead to
culture and the answer is I personally
cannot because I am NOT a Deadhead but I
will tell you in terms of the overall
the business of hubspot the entire
reason the company exists the overall
idea which I didn't talk about but I did
not pay this person to give me a reason
at least tell you a little bit about
hubspot is we create this thing called
inbound marketing and the thesis is that
people hate being marketed to we hate
being cold called we hate spam we hate
junk mail all those things and hub spots
overall approach was to kind of change
marketing to make it more empathetic
more opens like here's what we're doing
this is why and you know openly
publisher pricing don't hide customer
reviews like all these positive things
that lots of companies just weren't
doing so our thesis is that in the long
run especially with the connectedness
than we have in the world transparency
Trump's
opaqueness in the long term period like
and whether it's culture whether it's
what you're selling its marketing it's
whatever it is and it's and I know I'm
going to be right the only question is
the time horizon rights like okay well
I'm going to be writer about some things
on transparency always trumping
opaqueness but like people just have
access to so much information now you
cannot get away with a crappy used to
get away with before and that's why
companies did it because they could ice
don't not only do I think it's the right
thing to do i think it's the optimum
thing to do yeah yes so you open a
singapore office last quarter yep we
plan to open the office in Tokyo yes
good so my question is when you
propagate your transparency culture yep
cross the country borders yep what are
the major problem he's good questions
the quietly so we're hubspot has offices
in Sydney Dublin Singapore we're opening
an office in Japan and how does this
translate how does our culture translate
across borders and things like that i'll
give you a a slightly long answer
because i think it's an important one of
all the decisions we've made at HubSpot
one of the toughest ones when we first
opened our remote office in dublin right
the reason is we were scared to death
because okay with our culture's this is
really realize we had like no offices
for the first like six years or so okay
we can open this office in dublin we
have no freakin idea how to take this
magic that's working here and transpose
it over to dublin we'd like we don't
know how to do that we don't have that
muscle group i know other companies have
done it and done it well we know it's
possible but we haven't done this we
were scared to death and so we ended up
doing we made a couple decisions i'm
gonna share the one with you that has
been the most impactful in terms of
increasing the odds of success and it's
going very well is when we went to
dublin we didn't do it for this reason
but dublin had depressed economy for
what ireland did overall leading up to
that and there were great tech companies
in dublin but they did what most
companies do when they go outside psycho
we're going to send our crappy projects
there we're going to go there for
because the labor is cheaper for
whatever reasons or whatever and we
didn't do that we did the exact opposite
which is ok here are the rights that
every hub spotter has these are hub
spotters therefore they have these
rights right so when we went into Europe
is like okay so we have unlimited
vacation
and people told us as I can and they
meant to facetiously it's like well you
can't have unlimited vacation in Europe
they'll never show up for work right
like that was and it turns out that's
not true right it's uh because and so we
do to that you have to still have
document having like a minimum thing or
whatever but and so we did is like we
said okay we're going to take all the
things that make up spot hubspot and
we're gonna try not to change the things
simply because it's possible for us to
do that or get away with it essentially
we tried to and that's helped as we've
done a bunch of other things that in
terms of bringing people back here and
trying to infuse it but it's one of the
things on my list of things that keep me
up at night is how do we take the thing
that's working right now it's like it's
yeah I don't end it on dark nope I'm
gonna I'll take one last question we'll
go way in the back there when you look
at the culture well that's do you see in
what challenges do they have typically I
don't think you do that feedback um yes
what's interesting hi David I haven't
seen him in eight years he was employee
number three in my first startup so the
question is how do we get okay so one of
things i did this is relatively recent
so at the end of the culture codec
there's an email address and its culture
Cottam spot calm and people and i invite
people to the deck advise people to
provide commentary and feedback good or
bad and i read every one of those emails
every single one respond to probably
ninety five percent of them the only
ones i don't respond to are the ones
that are self promotional spamming
trying to pitch me something and the
interesting thing is how universal some
of these ideas are like I so and I
before some of them to the team because
I think they're very very cool but
people from all walks of life look and
they're not even in tech they're not in
startups are just working for some
manufacturing firm in Boise Idaho or
something like I read the culture codec
and I was like nodding the whole way
through I've had he knows like this
thing made me cry like that kind of
stuff and it's very gratifying to kind
of see that like even though we're kind
of geek got him techie and weird and
sitting out in boston in our own little
bubble like sell these concepts seem to
like resonate with people unless very
gratifying sub and i haven't gotten any
which is surprising for the internet
like no hate mail and no it's like oh
well you're obviously doing this and
this the other thing just to take
advantage of employees and you're going
to try and put off deferred comp or
something I don't know what it is about
I've not gotten any which is I hi jinx
myself thank for your time this has been
a lot of fun huh
you